there she is of course performing Proud
Mary with Beyonce at the 2008 Grammys
remember she's older 60s here right yeah
long time Grammy's producer Ken Ehrlich
worked with Tina Turner on several
programs and he told us what it was like
to be behind the scenes during
rehearsals with Tina and Beyonce
it was electrifying to be in the room I
don't know that it was the first time
they met but it was certainly the first
time they worked together and Beyonce
was in awe you could see there was this
like in Tina Beyonce saw herself and in
Beyonce Tina show some of her show
she was known because of of what she did
on stage the minute the lights went on
you know she turned it on and she was
amazing but in person off stage she was
very she you know the we tossed the word
humble around a lot but that's what she
was